Tom who's your favorite actor in the
whole world
Liam Hemsworth is up there man he's
great he's great Hunger Games is really
good I have a question for Mr Chris
Pratt of all the actors in the world who
is your favorite actor all the actors in
the world go ahead Denzel Denzel
Washington yeah he's great yeah any
other hemsworths that Luke Hemsworth is
also super talented yeah super how about
an actor whose name begins with Tom
how about that Tom Cruise
he's great what if his second name began
with an eight Tom H thanks
oh I I see where this is going okay Tom
Hardy
try younger
still with the Tom H oh wow Hiddleston
oh yeah
[Applause]